Peggy's 16
hello and welcome to Stix shards of
darkness the new stealth infiltration
game from cyanide studio coming to ps4
Xbox one and PC join me for a moment to
learn about the new mechanics lore and
gameplay to be explored in Styx's new
adventure stolen by a dark elf
shapeshifter The Ambassadors scepter
powered by mysterious quartz is Styx
targeting Karanga a port village hosting
a diplomatic summit addicted to amber an
intrigued by the magical properties of
quartz Styx must infiltrate the port and
gain access for hel adran his latest
shadowy client and her airship using
verticality and shadows to your
advantage
sneak your way through the large open
spaces patrolled by elves humans dwarves
and other nuisances
today we'll be avoiding and killing the
humans and elves but it depends on your
playstyle keeping tabs on the amount of
noise you're making is an important
factor in your success land on carpets
to soften your fall and use ropes to
avoid a clumsy drop
clever use of the environment will keep
sticks hidden while other clever uses of
the environment will keep the enemy
hidden remember a dead guard is a quiet
guard
thinning out the patrols is one way to
play sticks shards of darkness and there
are multiple ways to do this throwing up
in there refreshments is one of them and
after some time they're bound to take a
drink leaving their bodies behind is a
great way to get busted scattered
throughout the level of many crafting
components so new feature and stick
shards of Darkness collecting these
essential ingredients will allow you to
craft many useful items which are
integral to some of the abilities you'll
see today crafting a bolt would allow
for a ranged attack useful in a bind and
the egg well you'll see how that's used
in a moment but first let's make sure
that if we are spotted we won't have
every elf between here in the Tower of a
knish on our tail
they're useful tip for some of the
inevitable missteps I was bad come and
take my ding-a-ling away
that noise made this will protect us
in the shadows your knife will light up
letting you know that your difficult to
be seen on the bottom right of your
screen you'll see an orange bar this is
your amber used to power sticks is
magical abilities getting from A to B in
this corridor is difficult with the
amount of enemies patrolling so clever
use of the ammo will illuminate useful
and dangerous objects in your path
allowing you to make better decisions on
how to move
invisibility provides an expensive but
effective cloak but they can still heal
yeah
those dumbasses left a window open how
nice of them inside things aren't quite
so bright
working in an advantage for our little
green friend clever use of sand to take
out the lights will provide an elements
of visual cover but the best way is
usually to climb high
with the egg we're able to create a
cocoon allowing sticks to throw a clone
of himself large distances and embody
that glory
using the bolt and a chemical potion we
can take out both of the guards pretty
easily
dissolving one body and carrying the
remaining body to a place to hide
but before Helen can attend the summit
the register must be adjusted with an
aim to avoid arousing suspicion for this
we can use the light to destroy us
and now it's written down in black and
women's it's his past yes but we'll keep
him here a little while longer this will
teach him to control himself I need to
get that pass okay let's head for the
docks
again using the environments a little
patience and observance opens
opportunities to take out guards but
with the register changed it's time to
open the gates
there are many paths to take throughout
each of the levels some more dangerous
than others and many of them hidden
sometimes the best way to avoid a fight
is to stick to the shadows and stick to
the walls
using the blimp we can alert the guards
to open the door and he'll adran can
attend the summit but we've reverted a
suspicious guard so we gotta hide
curiosity killed the Alf and we don't
even need to make an effort to hide him
this so-called fortress has more holes
one last check to make sure she's on her
way and we've completed about half of
the mission that takes place in the
mountainous port of Karanga
to find out what happens next stay tuned
to our next gameplay videos to find out
about all of the races features and new
mechanics to be discovered in sticks
shots of darkness coming to ps4 Xbox one
and PC